Et donc maintenant je travaille sur cette question :
comment puis-je obtenir ces images mentales de ma tête
sur mon écran d'ordinateur plus rapidement ?
Vous pouvez imaginer, si vous voulez,
un directeur de film ayant la possibilité d'utiliser son imagination seule
pour diriger le monde en face de nous ?
Ou un musicien pour extraire la musique de sa tête.
Il y a des possibilités incroyables,
comme un moyen pour les personnes créatives
de partager leurs pensées à la vitesse de la lumière.
Et la vérité est que ce qui coince encore pour être en mesure de le faire
est simplement d'augmenter la résolution des systèmes du scanner cérébral.
Alors laissez-moi vous montrer
pourquoi je pense que nous sommes assez proches du but
en partageant avec vous deux expériences récentes
de deux groupes précurseurs dans la neuroscience.
Les deux utilisaient l'IRMf --
technologie d'imagerie par résonance magnétique fonctionnelle --
pour créer des images du cerveau.
Et voici un scanner du cerveau de Giorgio Ganis
et de ses collègues à l'Université d'Harvard.
La colonne de gauche
montre un scanner cérébral d'une personne qui regarde une image.
La colonne du milieu
montre le scanner cérébral de cette même personne
qui imagine regarder cette même image.
Et la colonne de droite a été créée
en soustrayant la colonne du milieu de la colonne de gauche,
indiquant que la différence est quasi nulle.
Cela a été répété sur beaucoup de personnes différentes
avec beaucoup d'images différentes,
toujours avec un résultat similaire.
La différence entre voir une image
et imaginer voir cette même image
est presque inexistante.
Maintenant, permettez-moi de partager avec vous une autre expérience :
celle du laboratoire de Jack Gallant à l'université de Californie, Berkeley.
Ils ont réussi à décoder des ondes cérébrales
en champs visuels reconnaissables.
Permettez-moi de vous expliquer cela.
Dans cette expérience, on montrait aux individus
des centaines d'heures de vidéos YouTube
pendant qu'on scannait leur cerveau
pour créer un important répertoire de leur cerveau
réagissant à ces séquences vidéo.
Puis on leur montrait un nouveau film avec de nouvelles images,
avec de nouvelles personnes, de nouveaux animaux
et on enregistrait un nouveau répertoire de scanners.
L'ordinateur, en utilisant seulement les données des scanners cérébraux,
a décodé ce nouveau scanner cérébral et fournit une prédiction
de ce que l'individu était effectivement en train de voir.
Sur la droite, vous voyez la prédiction de l'ordinateur,
et sur le côté gauche, le clip présenté.
C'est ce qu'il y a de stupéfiant !
Nous sommes presque en mesure de le faire.
Nous avons juste besoin d'augmenter la résolution.
Et maintenant, souvenez-vous que lorsque vous voyez une image
par rapport à quand vous imaginez cette même image,
cela crée le même scanner cérébral.
Bon, cela a été fait avec les scanners possédant la plus haute résolution
disponible aujourd'hui,
et leur résolution a augmenté en fait d'environ mille fois ces dernières années.
Maintenant, nous devons augmenter la résolution
de mille fois encore
pour obtenir un aperçu plus profond.
Comment procédons-nous ?
Il y a beaucoup de techniques dans cette approche.
Une façon est de vous ouvrir le crâne et d'y mettre des électrodes.
Je ne suis pas pour.
Il y a beaucoup de nouvelles techniques d'imagerie proposées,
certaines même par moi,
mais étant donné le succès récent de l'IRM,
tout d'abord, nous devons nous poser la question,
est-ce que cette technologie est arrivée en fin de course ?
L'idée reçue est que
on obtient une résolution plus élevée avec des aimants plus gros,
mais à ce point, de plus gros aimants
n'offrent que des améliorations incrémentielles de la résolution,
pas les multiples de mille dont nous avons besoin.
Je mets en avant une idée :
au lieu de plus gros aimants,
faisons de meilleurs aimants.
Il y a quelques nouvelles percées de la technologie en nanoscience
qui lorsqu'elles sont appliquées aux structures magnétiques,
ont créé une toute nouvelle classe d'aimants,
et avec ces aimants,
nous pouvons établir des échantillons de champs magnétiques
vraiment très détaillés dans tout le cerveau,
et par leur biais, nous pouvons bel et bien créer
des structures d'interférence de type holographique
pour obtenir un contrôle de la précision sur beaucoup des échantillons,
comme on le voit ici en déplaçant les choses.
Nous pouvons créer des structures beaucoup plus compliquées
avec des dispositions légèrement différentes,
un peu comme pour faire un spirographe.
Alors pourquoi est-ce que c'est important ?
Beaucoup d'efforts avec les IRM au cours des années
ont apporté de très gros et vraiment énormes aimants, pas vrai ?
Et pourtant, la plupart des progrès récents dans la résolution
viennent en fait de solutions de codages et de décodages brillamment astucieuses
des récepteurs et émetteurs de fréquences radio F.M.
dans les systèmes d'IRM.
Au lieu d'un champ magnétique uniforme,
on met aussi en place des modèles magnétiques structurés
en plus des fréquences de radio F.M.,
de sorte a combiner les modèles magnétiques
avec les modèles de traitement des fréquences de radio F.M.
qui permettent d'augmenter de manière considérable
les informations que nous pouvons extraire
avec un seul scanner.
Et en plus de cela, nous pouvons ensuite superposer
nos connaissances sans cesse croissantes de la structure cérébrale et de la mémoire
pour créer l'augmentation multipliée par mille dont nous avons besoin.
Et à l'aide de l'IRMf, nous devrions être capables de mesurer
non seulement les flux sanguins oxygénés,
mais aussi les hormones et les neurotransmetteurs dont j'ai parlé
et ainsi peut-être même l'activité neuronale directe,
ce qui est le rêve.
Nous allons être en mesure de déverser nos idées
directement vers les médias numériques.
Pouvez-vous imaginer si nous pouvions dépasser la langue
et communiquer directement avec la pensée humaine ?
Que serions-nous capables de faire alors ?
Et comment allons-nous apprendre à gérer
les vérités de la pensée humaine non filtrée ?
Vous pensiez que l'Internet était grand.
Ces questions sont des questions énormes.
Cela pourrait être irrésistible comme outil
pour amplifier les compétences de notre pensée et de la communication.
Et en effet, ce même outil
peut s'avérer être la solution vers la guérison de la maladie d'Alzheimer
et de maladies similaires.
Nous n'avons pas vraiment le choix de ne pas ouvrir cette porte.
Indépendamment de cela, choisissez une année --
est-ce que ça arrivera dans 5 ou 15 ans ?
Difficile de croire que cela prendra plus de temps que cela.
Nous devons apprendre à franchir ce pas ensemble.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)